crowds on the streets of gaza city
people came out in numbers to celebrate
relieved that the violence of the past
few days
was finally over
the chairs and whistles began at 2 am
local time
as the cease-fire officially took effect
and the skies remained calm
israel's foreign ministry announced the
truce after the country's security
cabinet unanimously
accepted the deal but there were tense
times shortly before it started
rockets were still being fired from gaza
and israel's military carried out at
least one strike
on the streets of tel aviv there was a
mixed response
i think it's good the ceasefire is good
for humanitarian reasons
to let civilians relax a little bit on
both sides
i'm skeptical though that it will really
be kept for a while
i think this ceasefire won't last
eight hours they will start
shooting gas rockets again both hamas
and israel are claiming victory in the
conflict but both sides suffered in the
violence
gaza's hamas controlled health ministry
says at least 232 people
including more than 100 women and
children were killed in the fighting
and at least 12 people including
children were killed in
israel after rockets managed to evade
the country's iron dome
defense system u.s president joe biden
said the cease-fire was a genuine
opportunity for peace
he said washington would now help
replenish israel's defence capabilities
and help the palestinian authority with
humanitarian aid
and reconstruction in gaza these
hostilities have resulted in the tragic
deaths of so many
civilians including children and i send
my sincere condolences to all the
families
israeli and palestinians who have lost
loved ones
and my hope for a full recovery for the
wounded
but the scars of this conflict will take
a long time to heal
and what was destroyed in just a few
days will most likely take
years to rebuild
i'm joined now from gaza city by
journalist hasan balusha
hasan is the ceasefire there holding
where you are
so far it is uh it is holding gradually
um the the gaza streets
are back to normal still today is a
weekend the friday is one of the
main weekend days in gaza
thousands of those who refuse to uh to
honor
schools and and and uh to their friends
and families houses returned to their
uh homes uh especially those from the
border areas in the northern gaza strip
and and uh eastern bar uh
some workers from the municipality are
walking the street of paving and and
and taking out the rubble off of the
road uh so gradually
so far it is holding and and and life is
going back
this must be come as much of a relief
for the residents in gaza
it is uh actually after 10 uh
or 11 days of of fighting and and
bombardment
uh palestinians are relieved they
celebrated this
partially the from hamas they celebrated
because it was a victory according to
them
for ordinary people many of them they
they they are relieved because
and celebrated because it's over and
they survived this
this war can you tell us anything about
the terms
of this ceasefire deal
well according to the statement that
issued from from
egyptian side that it is it is a
ceasefire
and uh two delegation uh from egyptian
security will be sent to to gaza streb
and to tel aviv to discuss further
details of
uh permanent ceasefire between the both
sides
hamas is saying that the deal include
that
israel would stop violation
against palestinian in jerusalem
especially at al-aqsa mosque on sheikh
but it wasn't clear at the in the
statement that issued by the egyptian
side
so far it's unclear
on the details but the most important
for the
the people here and the residents in
gaza that it's over
yes indeed and now hamas is of course
portraying this as a victory
will ordinary people in gaza see it that
way
some of the i mean hamas has a
popularity in gaza and
and according to many analysts that
hamas popularity
go up uh hamas
some some people are talking about that
this battle was
was a kind of a victor a victory for
hamas as they
they uh this is the first time that
the title of this war is not gaza and
the blockade imposed in gaza but
jerusalem
jerusalem and al-aqsa mosque is is very
important for palestinians not only in
gaza but
even elsewhere and in the west bank or
in abroad some of the celebrations
in gaza and and even in the west bank
uh clearly talked about that this is a
very important moment for
for the palestinians
some 230 people killed their thousands
more
displaced infrastructure destroyed how
long will it take gaza to recover from
this
from from previous experiences that the
the reconstruction would take
years uh now is the struggle about
excuse me so part of the deal is that
egypt announced about
500 million dollars would be donated
whether directly from egypt
from or from other countries but uh
uh the these some some of the houses
that they were destroyed and
buildings from 2014 still un and
rebuilt yet um so these
these things is the most difficult for
the ordinary people
uh devastating is not clear enough
how bad is that definitely there were
four at least four high buildings were
destroyed many houses were destroyed in
across the gaza strap so these uh
and many of the infrastructure in in
in the gaza strip as well that were
damaged
so these will take uh some time the the
most important part is the money so the
money
once the money comes from from the
donors
it will stop but definitely it will take
years
all right how's in belush in gaza thanks
very much for that
now let's turn to tel aviv where dw
correspondent donna regev is standing by
donna is the ceasefire holding there too
and how are israelis reacting
yes rebecca well the ceasefire so far
has been holding no rockets have been
launched
into israel from the gaza strip most
people here in israel
uh welcome this cease-fire with open
hands
much like the people in gaza they are
also happy that this
escalation of violence is over however
we do hear
some voices who express concern uh
regarding the
uh the terms of the peace
of the the the truth they're not sure
what is included uh like my colleague
here from gaza said
uh we also don't know nothing was
published here officially
we do hear some critical voices of why
uh the inclu why the bodies of two
soldiers that are being held in gaza
as well as an israeli civilian who is
believed to be alive there
why they were not included in this truth
uh otherwise most people are very happy
about it
and how is this being seen politically
is there much public support for the
government
yes well this is this is they're really
mixed react reactions about this
on the one hand uh netanyahu sees this
as an achievement
uh all over the media there are
publications of
claiming that israel has reached its
targets
even if it's unknown what the targets
really were that it really
hit the ability of hamas to launch
rockets
but it also needs to be said that
because netanyahu called this uh
truth unconditional then it's also a bit
difficult to judge him about what these
conditions
really are once they will be revealed or
exposed then he will probably face a
harsher criticism politically in the
long run
uh nobody in israel or in gaza dares to
even imagine
something like a peace agreement or a
renewed oslo accords
now that external peace uh looks like it
will hopefully return what about
internal divisions between jewish
israelis and arab israelis
yeah this is here where i stand in jaffa
which is the southern part of tel aviv
is a mixed area
and this is probably going to be the
most difficult thing to repair
here the in only 11 days the trust that
people shared or had in one another has
been damaged so deeply
people were lynched as we've seen in
previous days in the streets
people got killed from uh gunfire in
the middle of uh israeli cities with
mixed communities so
the municipalities themselves as well as
the government and local
uh citizens that will have to remain
alongside each other for years the same
way they have been living alongside each
other for decades
they will have a lot of work uh to do to
restore
the trust and that that people have in
one another and that was lost
indeed dw correspondent donna regev
speaking to us from tel aviv thank you
you